el lazo rosa y el color rosa se ha
convertido en símbolo de la lucha contra
el cáncer de mama pero representa este
lazo rosa a todas las pacientes pues
conversamos con Pilar rocilla paciente
de cáncer de mama metastásico y
activista por la campaña revienta el
lazo rosa y también lazo boca abajo
Gracias Pilar por estar con nosotros en
directo América de Francia 24 también
más Romero sala está con nosotros en el
estudio Buenos días Raúl y buenos días
Pilar también Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos lo primero que te queríamos
preguntar Es realmente no Cuál es el
motivo detrás de este reventar el rosa o
de pedir el lazo boca abajo cuéntanos
bueno Pues precisamente hace unos meses
estábamos hablando con una compañera que
también tiene cáncer de mama metastásico
Y decíamos bueno pues ya pronto se
avecina octubre y empezarán a salir los
lacitos las camisetas las gorras las
absolutamente todo el marketing rosa
porque el rosa vende mucho al final hay
un tema de género no ha pegado al color
rosa y ella me decía Es que mira que me
gusta el rosa no pero es que me revienta
el rosa de octubre y se quedó esa idea y
rodando y con otras compañeras que he
tenido el placer de conocer en estos
meses que llevo de casi un año de
diagnóstico desde las redes sociales
dije Oye por qué no vamos un poquito más
allá porque no hacemos ruido o sea no es
rosa el cáncer de mama hay muchas cosas
que pueden ser rosas muchos aspectos de
nuestra vida pueden ser rosas pero el
cáncer no lo es y de ahí dijimos cambiar
el color del lazo era una gesta titánica
y al final tampoco tenemos una enemistad
con el color podría ser este y Ya está
nos ha tocado el rosa pero seamos un
poco subversivos no el que hemos pues lo
ponemos boca abajo boca abajo porque
porque cada año fallecen muchísimas
mujeres y algunos hombres no lo
recordemos también o sea no lo olvidemos
que hay un 2% de los diagnósticos que
afectan a hombres
eso no es rosa Las múltiples
secuelas efectos secundarios de los
tratamientos no sonrosas las
mastectomías no son rosas la muerte
no es rosa o a como el rosa se ha
vendido tradicionalmente en nuestras
culturas a partir de de esa de esa idea
Pues fuimos creciendo creciendo buscamos
otras chicas montamos la campaña del
revienta el rosa que se puede hacer
perfectamente desde casa ya sea
reventando un globo rompiendo un papel
de color rosa el hecho de decir el rosa
no representa el cáncer de mama como tal
y después por la calle el gesto de girar
luego boca abajo como como os decía como
un objetivo de
visibilización en las calles No de hecho
hoy ha sido muy bonito porque hemos
salido a dar una vuelta y había varias
personas que llevaban el lazo boca abajo
no solo familiares o conocidos sino
personas a las que les ha llegado la
campaña Y eso sí que genera mucha
compañía y al final es el decir no
estamos solas o sea somos muchas y
muchos Pilares en lo que entiendo es que
digamos el color rosa romantizaría Por
así decirlo un poco esta enfermedad tan
dura como lo es el cáncer de mama eh
sobre todo en las mujeres que la
población más afectada evidentemente
como lo decías no hay que olvidar que
también lea los hombres pero las mujeres
evidentemente son las más afectadas por
esta enfermedad y digamos que también
una crítica a lo que estábamos hablando
previamente a a tu intervención Mary yo
no de estas compañías que se enriquecen
en torno a esta enfermedad no que puede
ser hasta perjudicial para todas las
pacientes con cáncer de mama
claro al final tú generas un producto
por el cual vas a tener un beneficio y
si está bien que dones una pequeña parte
a ello pero es que tú estás obteniendo
un beneficio aprovechándote del color
rosa que sabemos que tiene mucha venta o
sea si fuera de otro color probablemente
no tendría el mismo el mismo impacto de
hecho el lazo original era de color
melocotón o sea es una es una
estiloderno quien quien decide usar el
color rosa con una visión de mercadeo
muy importante y no niego que haya una
mala fe O sea que realmente se destina
un dinero pero yo al final digo si tú
vas a comprar una camiseta rosa por
poner un ejemplo y vas a gastar a 10
dólares para que dos sean donados a la
investigación por qué no donas esos 10
dólares a la investigación porque yo no
necesito que las personas lleven
camisetas de color rosa yo lo que
necesito es que haya más tratamientos a
día de hoy el cáncer que yo padezco es
un cáncer de mama metastásico no tiene
cura y hay muchas compañeras en tamaño
de qué estado de diagnóstico que que no
han podido superar esta enfermedad
entonces necesitamos más investigación y
menos mercadeo de color rosa y mucho más
si son productos como alcohol o otros
productos y que tienen un alto riesgo o
que suman a esos factores para poder
padecer cáncer de mama Sí aquí también
queríamos decir no como por ejemplo en
América Latina hay mujeres que se tienen
que endeudar para poder costear los
tratamientos de cáncer de mama en España
o en Europa la realidad es en algunos
casos se pueden parecer en otras diferir
pero entonces aquí quería hacerte esa
pregunta no Cuáles son esas
reivindicaciones de las que deberíamos
estar hablando hoy no que puedan
despertar cambios social más allá Pues
del lazo o del mercadeo que hay detrás
de esto
creo que es muy importante entender que
la prevención es y con cuidado no quiero
dar miedo no con esto pero sí que es
verdad que la prevención en las
autoexploraciones son sumamente
importantes pero necesitamos más
investigación en cuanto a tratamientos
porque de qué sirve que una persona se
encuentra un bulto si por ejemplo en el
caso de España a partir de los 50
empieza las mamografías preventivas en
Yo estoy en contacto con chicas de 18 de
30 Sí yo tengo 43 fue diagnosticada con
42 O sea a mí las mamografías
preventivas no estaban
a mi alcance sí Entonces eso es eso es
un problema importante y se tiene que
ver porque hay como una idea de que el
cáncer de mama es como el cáncer Bueno
yo he llegado a oír esa expresión no
cuando tú dices tengo cáncer hay
personas que te dicen de qué Y cuando
dices de mama es como Ah bueno un añi
malo y cuidado no solo es un añito malo
o sea es que hay un tipo unos tipos de
cáncer que no se curan y luego otros que
aunque tengan mejor pronóstico van a
tener efectos secundarios muy
importantes durante muchísimos años
entonces de entrada el hecho de que la
prevención es importante pero que no es
lo único que necesitamos y después a
nivel de las de los sistemas de salud de
todos los países si es verdad que tengo
la suerte de vivir en un país en el que
parte de mi tratamiento está
prácticamente el 90 y 9% de mi
tratamiento está cubierto pero tengo
compañeras por ejemplo triple negativo
metastásicas a las que se les acaba de
prohibir un fármaco Que Tiene bastantes
buenos resultados porque se considera
que no es costo efectivo significa que
el dinero pasa por delante del valor de
la vida como mides una vida Cuánto vale
la vida de una persona un mes más de
vida aunque sea es que estamos hablando
de un costo muy alto es que nos va la
vida en ello y en otros países es aún
más difícil personas que se embargan
para pagar tratamientos personas que
directamente Aunque tengan Cómo pagar el
tratamiento no tienen acceso a ese
tratamiento porque en sus países
no hay una buena comunicación para que
lleguen los medicamentos en tiempo y
forma de manera que tenemos que poner
todo ese debate sobre la mesa y que está
muy bien que las personas salgan a la
calle con sus lazos rosas yo lo llevo y
llevo mi lazo boca abajo pero llevo mi
lazo rosa para visibilizar pero es que
tenemos que llegar un poco más arriba o
sea esto no se ha acabado aún hay muchas
personas que mueren por cáncer de mama
cada vez el
la estadística va subiendo antes era una
de cada 9 después una de cada ocho ahora
prácticamente es una de cada siete el
cáncer de mama en hombres también está
empezando a elevarse
creo que tenemos que poner muchas cosas
sobre la mesa